eu começo dizendo que só o que morre
pode renascer
todo dia a gente morre um pouco todo dia
a gente renasce um pouco nesse sentido
desenvolver a capacidade criativa é uma
forma de voltar à vida após morrer
ao longo dos últimos anos eu poderia
dizer eu tenho pesquisado bastante sobre
a capacidade criativa do ser humano a
capacidade de transformação do ser
humano a isso a gente tem dado o nome de
letramento criativo da transformação
pelo design cada segundo é o tempo que
se tem é a melhor forma de aproveitar
cada segundo é ter noção exata de que a
gente morre ea gente nasce a cada
segundo a cada oportunidade que a gente
tem porque falar em design
durante muito tempo o design foi
encarado como uma cereja do bolo no
final do processo
com o passar dos anos as pessoas
começaram a atribuir ao design uma
conotação um pouco de maior valor
começaram a dizer que na metáfora do
bolo design seria então a farinha o
início do processo para dar sustentação
e com o passar dos anos e eu poderia
dizer nos tempos atuais
nós percebemos uma mudança um pouco para
desmate cá eu poderia dizer onde o
design começou a ser entendido não mais
como a cereja no final do bolo apenas e
não mais como a farinha no início apenas
nós como elemento questionador que
questiona a necessidade do próprio bolo
quem é que disse que eu preciso de um
bolo ou seja de que maneira que eu possa
desenvolver uma capacidade crítica do
status quo do meu entorno e promover a
partir daí alavancas para a mudança a
partir de ferramentas criativas do
desenvolvimento criativo
o design ele transforma contextos
nós aprendemos a desenhar começamos a
nos expressar muito antes da língua pelo
desenho e pela gráfica a cia
começamos a nos comunicar enquanto seres
humanos pelo desenho
o design transformou com textos na idade
média transformou com textos no próprio
renascimento quando desenho começa a
ganhar uma atribuição inclusive
projetual ea gente pode citar grandes
nomes da humanidade como leonardo da
vinci que desenhou máquinas cem anos
antes mesmo dessas máquinas serem
produzidas
o design revolucionou a indústria também
a data de nascimento do design enquanto
o desenho industrial na revolução
industrial quando se desenhou não apenas
a capacidade de gerar escala com
produtos mas se desenhou uma economia
predominantemente centrada no produto
sendo que desde a década de 60 nós
vivemos um deslocamento de uma economia
de um produto para uma economia de um
serviço e hoje se fala muito além do
serviço se fala em experiência nesse
sentido o design começou a transformar
negócios
o design começou a ser um elemento
fundamental para repensar modelos
ultrapassados que nasceram em uma época
a qual o desenho econômico era
compatível com os desafios da época
não vivemos mais esse tempo não podemos
mais e resolver problemas complexos com
a mesma lógica mecânica que os criaram
na mesma sequência o design tem mudado a
sociedade
a gente fala muito em inovação social a
gente fala em economia 2.5
a gente fala em diversas transformações
por meio do design
existe um o último elemento um sexto
elemento que eu poderia dizer o design
transforma vários contextos aqui é
apenas um resumo né
mas eu poderia solidifica todos eles em
um o contexto da educação o design tem
transformado radicalmente a educação tem
promovido um redesenho da educação
e nesse aspecto quando a gente fala em
educação
a gente fala em uma experiência a qual
eu gostaria de trazer pra vocês que é
uma experiência pessoal durante muito
tempo lá no meus 1909 meus 11 anos 1900
e não quero falar sobre isso
eu tinha muitos problemas na escola
então era muito ativo muito né era super
ativo gostava muito de desenhar e era um
assíduo freqüentador do soe
não sei se vocês lembram que é o sonho
mas é só um departamento na escola que
trabalha com crianças como eu né
problemáticas e eu freqüentava tanto só
eu mas tanto que às vezes eu chegava não
soe antes mesmo da professora do soe ela
chegava eu já estava lá sentado e ela
perguntava o que foi dessa vez daniel né
e normalmente eu visitava o sol e pelas
mesmas razões
eu amava desenhar estava sempre
desenhando desenhava no caderno dos
outros se alguém saía para o intervalo
para no banheiro voltava de um desenho
no caderno do cara na última página a
última folha do caderno emblemática né
desenhava na classe enfim mas aquilo não
era entendido como uma capacidade
criativa que era entendido como
vandalismo e então eu era suprimido da
sala de aula né
e eu assinei já naquela época muitos
contratos
os contratos que eu assinava aqueles
cadernos que havia na escola onde se
chamava termo de compromisso é termo de
compromisso pra para a melhoria de
comportamento para que no próximo ano eu
não fosse expulso da escola então e e lá
estava eu sempre desenhando e eu sempre
desenhei eu sempre procurei desenhar e
mas eu sempre era repreendido e eu nasci
me desenvolvi e convive com esse estigma
de que aquilo que eu fazer algo ruim
eu fico pensando se a história não teria
sido diferente sim uma aula de história
uma aula de geografia quem sabe eu
tivesse sido convidado para ilustrar o
que o professor estava falando talvez
ilustrar a esquemas de taxonomia
biológica
se eu não tivesse talvez tido essa
oportunidade se eu tivesse tido essa
oportunidade talvez eu teria lhe
ressignificado o meu papel enquanto
profissional de design mas o que a gente
precisa entender que a criatividade é
inerente ao ser humano
nós temos apenas duas escolhas assim
como os processos na criatividade
inerente ao ser humano a nossa vida
ou a gente desenvolve a criatividade
controla o processo metodológico do
saber criativo ou a gente faz isso aí ó
a gente reza para que as coisas dêem
certo e saiam como a gente espera porque
o controle do processo metodológico nós
não temos e eu me considero um
sobrevivente picasso falou isso é um
verdadeiro milagre sobrevivermos de
maneira criativa ou seja nos mantermos
criativos ao longo de um processo
educacional formal e eu me considero um
sobrevivente porque eu continuei
desenhando desenhando muito apaixonado
pelo desenho e encontrei nessa passagem
inclusive do garner quando ele falou
sobre inteligências múltiplas no caso
inteligência existencial e ele definiu
assim se uma pessoa não encontra
significado na sua vida profissional ela
se torna em produtiva ela se torna
insatisfeita
eu precisava encontrar algo que desce
vazão para aquilo que eu mais amava
desenhar
nesse sentido ingressei no ano de 2000
escapou ano agora ingressei na faculdade
de desenho industrial e comecei a
desenvolver essa capacidade criativa de
projeto de produto de comunicação visual
e comecei a despertar uma paixão que nem
mesmo eu sabia que havia dentro de mim
pelo desenho pela transformação de
contextos
alguns anos depois eu pude desenhar o
primeiro produto um produto simples mas
um produto que eu tirei do papel
muitos colegas faziam projetos para
passar em disciplinas e eu fazia
projetos pra mudar a vida de pessoas
então o desenho um triciclo adaptado
construir ele começou
as mãos quase perdeu um braço em um
acidente em uma serra circular
adorava mexer na marcenaria adorava
mexer com os equipamentos e o triciclo
foi doado por uma escola com mais de 400
alunos com necessidades especiais
o triciclo de um sistema de redução de
marcha onde há mesmo sem força motriz
significativa a criança conseguiu se
colocar em movimento e desenvolver a
capacidade a motriz das pernas há alguns
anos depois após me formar também eu
continuei desenhando então ingressei no
segmento educacional continue no mercado
de trabalho como consultor e pude
desenvolver um sonho que era um
congresso nacional de design e
responsabilidade social onde vieram
articulista de outros países inclusive
publica seus artigos onde nós
desenvolvemos a temática da
sustentabilidade nos níveis inclusive
que nós vimos aqui antes né
nos diversos níveis e principalmente dos
equipamentos desenvolvidos para pessoas
com necessidades especiais
ao chegar em porto alegre no ano de 2010
eu tive a oportunidade também de
continuar desenhando conseguir
desenvolver junto com uma equipe de
pessoas que também acreditava no desenho
como catalizador da transformação social
uma intervenção em uma creche
comunitária onde o design intermediava
outras áreas do conhecimento como a
arquitetura como engenharia como
pedagogia e transformávamos contextos de
vulnerabilidade social cento a da vila
cruzeiro em mudança social consigamos
trazer esperança para crianças para
docentes e para famílias gerando renda
com o desenvolvimento de produtos eu
continuava desenhando
hoje eu continuo desenhando eu atuo em
uma instituição de ensino que acredita
no design como uma ferramenta poderosa
na transformação social para o
desenvolvimento da visão sistêmica
desenhos que dão origem a políticas que
facilitam a comunicação que fortalecem o
pensamento estratégico e que provam que
nós somos mais do que a soma das nossas
inteligências lógico matemática ou
linguísticas esses aspectos estão vendo
são as inteligências múltiplas de
gardner
se a gente colocar a inteligência
criativa como uma décima inteligência no
centro ela conecta todas as outras
o problema é que a escola tem nos matado
a escola mata nossa criatividade
somos heróis em continuar criativos ao
longo da formação formal né
e esse campo tenso que existe em cobre
todas as nossas capacidades que elas não
ocorrem de maneira regular elas são
irregulares
as nossas inteligências múltiplas e cada
vez que eu recuo que eu diminuo o campo
tenso
cada vez que eu me torno mais à vontade
mais fluido mais confiante eu consigo
tornar visível as minhas capacidades
isso acontece o tempo todo o tempo todo
nós morremos o tempo todo nós renascemos
nas nossas idéias nos nossos projetos
nas nossas alianças estratégicas
o tempo todo se a gente reduz o campo
tenso ainda mais a gente consegue ter
uma visão geral do que nós somos das
nossas capacidades das nossas
inteligências múltiplas e conseguimos
entender inclusive com base nas
ferramentas corretas quais são aquelas
inteligências que nós devemos
desenvolver se uma inteligência
existencial ser uma inteligência
linguística ciao inteligência lógico
matemática ea partir do momento que a
gente consegue desenvolver esse espectro
de inteligências a gente conecta todas
elas ea gente consegue gerar mais
repertório repertório criativo para
soluções de problemas e quanto mais
repertório nós geramos nesses espectros
de ferramentas
nesse conjunto específico de ferramentas
mas nós desenvolvemos a nossa capacidade
criativa ea nossa confiança criativa
para poder mudar com textos para poder
revolucionar contextos para conseguir
fazer com que isso rod
eu costumo comentar a respeito de três
lentes são as lentes do letramento
criativo é necessário que nós temos
consciência de que tudo o que a gente
precisa fazer hoje em
vi essa vai está muito presente no mundo
corporativo é necessário ter uma causa
têm um propósito
as empresas já perceberam isso marcas
carismáticas elas geram margens pra
altas e altas margens de lucro porque os
seus clientes eles julgam essas marcas
insubstituíveis eles fidelizam ao ponto
de gerar lucratividade
então o mundo corporativo já percebeu
isso mas inovação não vem de máquina
inovação vem de gente e se a gente tem
proposta a gente tem uma causa
as pessoas se vinculam a nossa causa
elas acreditam saibam cena que disse
isso quando citou luther king
mas não basta a propósito um propósito
pessoal é necessário relevância uma
relevância inclusive em termos sociais
para quem a gente está fazendo isso
a vida de quem a gente está mudando com
isso a busca do nosso porque que muito
cedo
no meu caso eu achei que era o desenho
mas eu precisei sobreviver a um contexto
que mata a criatividade além do
propósito e além da relevância é
fundamental que a gente tenha
conhecimento
a técnica a técnica correta para o
momento correto
paulo freire já dizia né se nós temos 30
alunos nós temos 30 aulas
nós temos 30 problemas nós temos 30
oportunidades ou seja o nosso universo
individual cada um de nós somos universo
a intersecção dessas três lentes
hospedam o conceito de letramento
criativo
se nós temos conhecimento temos
propósito temos relevância
nós temos condições de desenvolver a
nossa capacidade criativa a nossa
confiança criativa para finalizar eu
trago uma mensagem de um guru que não
consta nos livros de design não consta
nos livros de inovação e não consta
também nos
de administração de gestão mas ele tem
uma definição sensacional acerca de
inteligência
o cristo da morte disse que inteligência
está relacionada não acumulação de
experiências ou de conhecimento
ele define inteligência assim
inteligência é o mais alto grau de
sensibilidade
quando nós temos sensibilidade os nossos
sentidos se tornam mais aguçados
nós nos tornamos mais sensíveis ao meio
ea nossa capacidade de absorção de
oportunidades de leitura e de geração de
empatia com o outro se torna mais
potente
nós morremos e nós nascemos todo dia
a mensagem que eu gostaria de deixar
para vocês aqui é que me ajudem e se
ajudem a não matar a criatividade
criatividade é um processo de letramento
criativo é a luz no fim do túnel que não
é o trem certo
muito obrigado pela atenção de vocês